let's do dine representation and
analysis what's the mean what's a
synonym for mean average that's exactly
right so to get an average you got to
add up all of these scores and then you
have to divide by however many scores
there are so that's what you can see
happening here
add it all up there are seven in total
so the sum of the scores is 28 divided
by seven just gives you four that's the
mean the median what's our what's that
phrase that tells us what median means
it's that it's the middle score isn't it
right and so to get a better score here
you got to put them in order you have to
put otherwise you don't know which one's
the middle one cuz they're you know if I
said what's the median height and I just
went along you right now you're not in
any order so I don't know who's in the
middle really okay so that's why you can
see you put them in the proper order and
there are seven scores in total so the
middle one is the fourth one and you can
see this three on one side and three on
the other that's how you have five we
did mean we did media that means the
last one left is mode which is the it's
the it's the highest frequency or the
most common score okay so you just look
at you see is there any particular
scholar - more common than the others
the answer is the only school that
doubles up is 17 so that's why that's
the answer
all right now this one's tricky the mean
of five scores is six the four of the
scores are shown below and is a missive
score so here they're mixing data with
algebra right that's the Missy's score
so you can let that equal to X and then
you can work out the mean just the same
way that you did before you have to add
these numbers up you get X plus 20 but
you want the X on its own so you keep
the five over to the other side becomes
6 times 5 and you can see how the
numbers play out yeah 30 on the left
hand side x plus 2y on the right hand
side take away 24 both sides and that's
where your 10 comes from and you can
check that out or you can go and add all
of these work out the average and sure
enough you get 6
okay you have a table here we did these
tables quite a lot so hopefully you did
okay working out that F times X
frequency times the score
you just had to multiply across so one
times three equals three two times four
equals eight three times five is fifteen
and so on then you had to add these up
you use the table to determine that mean
and mode so what you had to do was well
the boat is not too hard to work out you
just look at the most common score the
most common score the highest frequency
is five so the score the chorus plus 2
that is the 3 that's the moon the mean
is you have to divide all the scores add
up over how many scores are and that's
where 2.6 comes from yeah we can fix
that up a little make a note for me not
on the paper that it depends if you're
working is legitimate I can have a look
at it because the idea rather to my
question is if you do some kind of
correct working for instance if you've
got the marks in order that stands for
something right even if you identified
the role what is the media so I'll have
to have a look at that okay so let me
come back we're doing that we use the
table of 3000 divided by 15 gives you
that find the modal class modal class
just means it's one of these the one
that's most frequent right so you have a
look and you see which one has the
highest frequency nie is the highest
frequency the class the course was that
is 7 to 9 steadily what's what's the
highest mark so remember how to read
these right they even give you a key
where this see where you see a 4 and in
between the stem of the leaf you up that
loan there and then a 7 right that's
gonna be 47 so if you like these are
kind of like your TENS units sorry your
tens digits and these are your units
digits okay so the highest mark is going
to be 50 something it's 57 you just read
it off the top how many suits did the
exam you have to count out how where do
you leaves there are each leaf
represents
your student so that's where you at 27
from what's the median mark just like
before you got accounts in the middle
luckily for you these marks are in order
actually you don't need to redraw this
thing you just need to count down one of
the easiest ways is to say you cancel
one of the bottom one on the top one at
the bottom one at the top and you keep
going until you can't go any further and
you'll get 31 that mark there
that's your medium over the page you
doing well last statistics question we
have to find range we have to find burn
what is range it's there to the highest
which is fine
minus the lowest that's where you get
five minus one from that's for once the
mode again it's the most common score
the score which has the most people on
it and that looks to me like it's that's
true that's the highest okay so that's
where that murder comes from and that's
all of data